hello and welcome to this video on the
European standard on electronic
invoicing the e-invoicing directive
calls for the definition of a common
european standard on electronic
invoicing the directive dictates that
Member States shall adopt it so that it
will become mandatory for all
contracting authorities and contracting
entities to receive in process e'en
voices complying with the European
standard this video will explain three
important components of the e-invoicing
standard the core the sires and
extensions to do this we'll have a look
at a couple of examples Maria works for
the central government and is
responsible for procurement she buys
phone services from Lucy who works for a
phone service company Maria and Lucy
take on the role of buyer and seller in
this scenario likewise we have Dmitry
working for a public hospital and
Bernhard a food manufacturer they to
exchange goods and services in the role
of buyer and seller both buyers request
goods or services in large quantities
and have a long-term relationship with
the sellers both buyers receive an
electronic invoice now when comparing
the invoices we see many similarities
but there are some differences in the
invoice that Lucy sends to Maria we find
the name and address of both buyer and
seller a description of the service the
invoice amounts and phone usage
information
on the invoice that burn incense to
Dmitri we also find the name and address
of both buyer and seller a description
of the service the invoice amounts but
we also find something called the
product batch information now imagine if
Dmitri buys the phone service from Lucy
and receives Lucy's invoice Dmitry
cannot properly process the invoice as
his computer was expecting to receive
the product batch information but
instead it got the phone usage
information field and hence cannot
process it to process the invoices
correctly it takes a technician to
adjust the invoice processing system
costing both time and money to his
Public Administration now many public
administrations face this challenge
especially in an economic environment
that is globalizing at a rapid pace now
the European Commission is removing this
barrier by introducing the European
standard on electronic invoicing the
team charged with developing the
european standard identified the
information that is used in most
invoices and based on this specified
what we call the core invoice some of
the core information is mandatory in all
invoices but some of it is optional and
is included only when necessary in all
cases if both seller and buyer conformed
to the european standard the seller will
know that if he sends the information
the buyer will be able to process it
correctly now Lucy knows that her
invoice will be processed correctly not
only by Maria but also by Dmitry and any
other public administration that follows
the European standard the standard
recognizes that the core may not suit
all invoice exchanges for some there may
be too much information while others may
want additional information there are
those two distinct variations that can
apply let's examine the first one in the
following scenario in which options are
being removed some information elements
in the core invoice allow for options
for example in regard to payment
instructions the core allows for
multiple payment options including a
separ credit transfer non separate
transfer direct debit or the element can
be left empty since in some cases
payment method is defined in the
contract now let's suppose to meet she
needs to limit these options to only
allow SEPA credit transfers to ensure
that he conforms with some legislation
this means that Demetri implements a
restricted version of the standard that
has been made available that those who
fall under this legislation the standard
cause this a call invoice usage
specification or a situs for short
because this scientist is using just one
of the options provided by the core the
science falls within the European
standard and therefore Dimitri is fully
compliant the invoice can be processed
by anyone that supports the standard
without restrictions however even though
Sciences comply with the European norm
they may still challenge
interoperability in our example
Maria supports the full core invoice
without restrictions and Lucy always
uses non SEPA credit transfer as a
payment option in her invoices she can
send her invoice to Maria who can
process it without an issue but when
sending to Dimitri
she must adjust her invoice to Dimitri
science to limit such conflicts and
reduced the need for adjustment it's
advised that buyers are able to receive
the full core invoice or adopt common
sizes that are widely used
in the following scenario we'll take a
look at the other variation on the
European norm where information is added
maria receives phone information from
Lucy and she wants all phone service
companies to send her this information
for this she may implement except toriel
extension that may have been developed
for the phone service industry sector
where this extra business term is added
into the invoice specification and then
ask all phone service companies to
provided this information by supporting
the extension this variation is called
an extension in the European standard to
use an extension there must be a
bilateral agreement between the buyer
and the seller now Lucy and Maria can
continue doing business as before and
Maria can receive the phone information
from other phone suppliers who willing
to support the extension but because the
invoice is not following the core
anymore these extended invoices will not
be processed by Lucy's other buyers who
only accept the standard without
extensions because extended invoices
require bilateral agreements they fall
outside of the European norm therefore
everyone must support the core or Esaias
to comply with the standard even though
they may also use extended invoice by
agreement with certain business partners
thank you for watching alongside this
video sefie invoicing offers a free
service package that gets you started
with the invoicing in public procurement
and helps you comply with the European
standard and its specifications it
includes services documentation and
tools come and check them out on SEF
digital and let's connect Europe
together